how can i that is this much of a mess be
written by Neil Gaiman seriously
[Applause]
[Music]
nightmare in silver I really don't like
this episode I think in some ways I
think I'm actually gentler on it now
that I was first time I saw it because I
already know I don't like it or as first
on my saw I was like god Neil Gaiman and
he's writing the Cybermen awesome and
then I saw oh my god it's so is not I
don't want to blame too much of this on
Gaiman though I feel like there's at
least a couple of key factors that
caused this stuff fail badly that were
outside of his control and maybe just
because I like him as a right or a lot
that I wanna I want to reason give the
guy a pass but let's start with the
first thing that I suspect Gaiman had no
control over Angie and Artie these kids
serve no narrative purpose whatsoever
contribute nothing Gaiman does not seem
at all comfortable writing kids of this
age their dialog is not natural Angie
especially is trying to be the
disaffected teenager she's just freaking
annoying unimpressed with everything
like I can't charge my phone oh my god
and I'm not gonna say that it's
unrealistic that like I could never
imagine a teacher and teenagers you're
doing that I could that's why you don't
take one Oh if there's ever an argument
to be had against the idea of there ever
being a child companion which I see
floated every now and then I think it's
the fact that consistently the writers
on this show gay men or anybody else are
not very good at writing kids nine times
out of ten at best these two are really
really annoying and they're useless and
the narrative is in no way benefit
by their presence and they make no
meaningful contribution they don't help
logistical II there's not involved
though matically I say that I'm not even
sure there are really themes going on in
this damn thing so that might be moot
anyway
they just add nothing so it's they're
starting out as neutral and then they're
really annoying so that's a negative
they should go the other big thing that
I don't think was gaymans fault but
feels like a massive massive misstep is
the entire way that mr. clever is done
so this is part of the cybermen
collective controlling consciousness
tries to take over the doctor and it
makes him play chess and they argue
inside his head
I'm down for all this what I don't get
though is why Matt Smith is playing mr.
clever basically identical to the doctor
there's like a slight bit more
malevolence but we've also seen this
doctor have those darker moments and so
it doesn't even feel that far off from
how the doctor is normally to my way of
thinking one of two things if not both
should have been done with this perform
and again this is not the writing this
is everything to do with the execution
so whether it was Matt Smith's choice as
a performer whether it was director I
don't know but either they should have
put some cyber modulation on his voice
which still could have been messed with
like have that be the normal
differentiator and then it tries to
trick Clara by dampening that down and
sounding like the real doctor but she
still catches it because it would have
it would have been a better misdirect
because otherwise like yeah we know we
know that was gonna happen but then you
know to have an auditory signifier to
differentiate that would have helped
or if you weren't gonna do that then he
should be playing the parts very
differently so like I get the idea that
it's not just this thing taking over the
doctor so it's not gonna completely
subsume the doctors personality it's
gonna be influenced by the doctors
personality on paper I get that but it
means that the actual clash the actual
conflict doesn't work fully when
actually watched and observed because
they're too dang similar plus they look
way too similar here's another thing I
wish I wish that in the headspace when
they're inside the doctors head arguing
I wish that the that mr. clever had
looked more inhuman like not just like
the view but like more I'm not like
stick a Cyberman head on him but like
more machined up like it's a pure
representation of what he views himself
as which would be less like the doctor
and more like a Cyberman just something
something other than blinky lights to
differentiate the two it it just feels
like such a missed opportunity that
instead of getting to see Matt Smith
stretch his legs and give us a
completely different performance it's
just the same performance except he
tilts his head down a lot more so that
he looks a little bit more m---eleven
like that's an old trick I got given
I've given that hint to that tip to
people doing burlesque like you can
change so much just by the angle like I
didn't change the right expression at
all but you got a different vibe didn't
you that's basically all he does he
tilts his head down and suddenly he's
mourning but there's no difference in
the performance so that's a massive loss
and a massive way something that should
have been awesome the doctor facing off
against a cybernetic version of himself
should have been amazing and it's
not the Cybermen it's trying to make
them scare again it's making them even
more upgraded even more powerful but
we're still just blowing them up see
again I like on paper this idea of these
things are so dangerous if there is even
one and we can't find it quickly we blow
up the planet because that's the safer
thing to do that's you telling me
something very scary but then what
you're showing me is a slight redesign
but we still we they still stomp around
like they always have and we can still
blow them up yes until they upgrade
which I guess makes them more like the
Borg now although it could be argued
that the Borg were kind of ripped off
from the Cybermen in the first place so
fair plate of that I suppose a Warwick
Davis hmm it was nice to have him along
I liked Warwick Davis in general and
it's not it I kind of feel nice that he
didn't have to be slathered in
prosthetics for this one he just got to
be there like hey good on you so yeah
that was cool that worked I just look at
the core components of this thing most
of them don't fit together you know
between these kids basically
blackmailing their way onto the TARDIS
and then to go to a rundown amusement
park okay slight connection and now
Cybermen no particular connection but
okay I suppose they can turn up
everywhere and now the doctor is being
taken over
okay well that feels like a like a plot
that should be more fleshed out really
kind of be the whole thing why were we
dallying about with these kids before oh
now there's a Cyberman army invasion
well hang on we were dealing with just
this thing of it taking over the doctors
mind that's plenty fair why don't we
beat a whole freaking army
oh also this guy turns out to be the
Emperor wait why do we even need an
emperor in this story I don't want to
make any accusations about how this was
or wasn't written but I look at Neil
Gaiman's best work or heck
I look at the doctor's wife and the
doctor's wife looked and felt and read
like something really carefully plotted
out with a lot of thematic threads and
recurring ideas and things that that
build on each other either from things
from previous episodes or within the
episode itself it felt like something
that someone had spent time lovingly
crafted this feels I'm not saying this
is what it is but this feels like
something thrown together to meet a
deadline this feels like if there were
ideas that anyone was really interested
in they didn't have the time to refine
them because probably about a third of
the concepts and this thing should just
be scrapped oh and plus the the the
squad of demoted people is that's just
their cuz okay it's it's it's a bit it's
just a bit of an undisciplined mess
nothing is building on each other it's
just kind of all thrown together I'm not
gonna say could never been turned into
something more workable but it needed
revisions it needed refinement it needed
streamlining this feels like second
draft out of six it's what this feels
like we're like you you did your first
draft where you don't even worry about
everything making sense you just get it
all down then you do your second draft
where you tie up the logistics and then
from there you start really refining and
really taking the the cleaver doing
being sure no that's not necessary beef
this up dude I feel like those steps
never happen they just did a second
draft they filmed the second draft of
the script that's what this thing feels
like and from a writer this good it just
is really disappointing and like I said
a waste of an opportunity in a number of
areas I really don't like this episode
I'm not even sure it's as bad as some of
the worst stuff out there it just
personally frustrates the ever-loving
hell
me nightmare and silver you rewashed it
lately what do you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it so come on back in a week
we'll keep on doing this and until next
time this council is adjourned thanks so
much for tuning in I hope you'll
consider hitting the like to subscribe
maybe even that bell + I naturally have
a patreon where folks support me and the
channel and some of those names you're
even gonna start seeing scrolling by
pretty soon so many things for you to
check out and do but you also don't have
to do any of it because at the end of
the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]